if there's one thing that really
turns our media on it's the extinction
of the human race
our media is perhaps more than anything
anti-human at least
anti-most humans as far as humans go
they like themselves and believe that
they themselves should continue existing
it's all the other humans especially
future generations of humans
that they aren't so sure about and
that's why the media is always eager for
any excuse to celebrate the so-called
child-free movement uh on that end
here's an article a recent article from
today.com it says
laura lavoy knew all her life she didn't
want to have children now 46
she never felt that draw she said part
of part of a growing
u.s population opting out of parenthood
a new study finds child free people are
as happy as
parents with the office authors
surprised by just how many men and women
indicated they didn't want to have kids
it's part of a larger trend of americans
having fewer children in general
the u.s birth rate fell to a record low
last year and there could be
300 000 to 500 000 fewer births in 2021
according to some estimates
for lavoy there were many reasons to
choose to be child free
quote the most important is that i just
don't want to raise children it's not
just it's just not something that has
ever appealed to me
i don't want to be responsible for
another human being in that way
lavoy a writer who lives in asheville
north carolina told today
but i also really like traveling i like
adventure
ever sitting in the same spot for very
long and just kind of lifestyle things
that don't really fit with having a
child
well yeah there's a word for that it's
called being superficial
and materialistic and selfish so that's
three words i suppose
it'd be a lot easier and get to the
point much quicker if these people would
just say that
to say i'm materialistic and selfish and
that's how i want to live my life
also i must note here you're not an
adventurer
because you spend thousands of dollars
to go to different tourist spots around
the globe
you want an adventure take four kids to
the grocery store okay adventure awaits
right down the street if you do that
that qualifies as an adventure at least
as much as flying down to cancun
and drinking 27 cocktails in a tourist
resort now the cancun trip may be more
relaxing i admit
but i'm just tired of these childless
couples acting like
they're exploring the amazon bragging
about their adventures
when they're being herded like cattle
from one tourist spot to the next
anyway back to the article it says her
husband feels the same way
she said they've been together 26 years
and
both agreed they didn't want to have
children they've discussed it over the
years but knew the answer would always
be the same
she noted over a quarter of adults 27
percent identified as child free in the
new study
27 percent um the number dramatically
exceeds previous estimates of two to
nine percent
reported by earlier studies the authors
said more than a third of child free
people 35
were in a partnered relationship
suggesting couples who don't want
children
quote represent an important type of
family they added
do they though i mean if you get married
and choose not to have kids
your family really isn't important in a
broader sense
it's important to you but not to anyone
else your family of two
could break apart any time and it would
have literally no effect on society in
the slightest
when you both die after after long there
will be no trace that
you ever existed except for your
headstone or that your relationship
existed
families with children on the other hand
are bearing the weight of the future on
our shoulders if our families break
apart
the consequences to society are immense
and catastrophic as we've seen
if we stay together though and raise our
kids well we've bestowed an immeasurable
blessing onto civilization
i can see how that qualifies as
important i don't see how mr and mrs
lavoy down in cancun opting for nicer
vacations and nicer cars
rather than propagating the human
species are doing anything important for
civilization
except by contributing to our
civilization's decline which i guess is
certainly consequential
if in a negative way now important to
mention here also
the article in the study draw a
distinction between so-called child-free
couples
and childless couples childless people
are those who want children but haven't
had them yet or can't have them for
whatever reason
child free people are those who've
chosen not to have them and not to adopt
so everything i'm saying here applies
only to the latter to child free
people who want children but can't have
them have been given
a great burden and uh i feel sorry for
them the good news is
that their desire for children shows
that they're not self-centered
you know and they have a giving heart
and that's the pain
when you're childless and don't want to
be
um that you have a giving heart and
you're not self-centered
and you want to pour this love into a
family
but you can't have one for whatever
reason
um but as i said the good news is that
they'll find in other ways to contribute
to society to society and to make a
positive impact
because that's what selfless giving
people do the people like the lavoys are
a different story completely and that's
who we're talking about here and as far
as they go
i think two points should be made first
of all
um it doesn't make sense or at least
doesn't convey very much
to say that child free people are just
as happy as parents
only parents can really say whether
happiness increases upon becoming a
parent
so if you want to know that you got to
talk to parents they're the only ones
who can attest to it
because they've experienced life as
non-parents and as parents
they can testify to that experience but
a child free person by definition has
not experienced parenthood
doesn't know its joys and cannot know
what they're missing
as someone who myself has experienced
adult life both with kids and without
them
i would say that my happiness you could
look at it this way
my happiness cup may have been
you know nearly full before i had kids
but when i had them
the cup itself grew larger so there was
a greater capacity now for happiness
what i mean is i may have been mostly
satisfied with my life before kids
that's because i didn't know about the
deeper and greater joys that were
available through parenthood until i had
experienced them
the other thing about the happiness of
family life is that
you can access more and more of it as
you grow and virtue yourself which means
that as far as my case goes there's a
whole lot of happiness that i myself
have not yet accessed
you know because i'm still working on
the virtue part of it
um but any selfish person can enjoy a
vacation
and that's fine you know there's nothing
selfish about vacations those vacations
are good
but the happiness you derive is easy
it's surface level it's fleeting
that's what vacation is all about you
don't go on vacation to put in an effort
that's why
vacation is there the happiness of
parenthood and of marriage
for that matter is found though through
service and sacrifice
this means you have to put in the effort
to become a better person and the reward
is that you'll find deeper and deeper
joy in loving someone else
because the joy there is a lot of joy in
loving someone else
but it doesn't come automatically to
most people
you have to learn how to find joy in
that
on the other hand if you get married and
you have kids
and yet you remain a selfish spoiled
self-entitled brat like so many people
do
then you'll be just as miserable and
family life as you were before and over
time you'll be quite a bit more
miserable
and there are people i'm not going to
deny that these people exist who will
say that
sometimes quite openly say that they
regret having kids
it's not common but people talk about
this they regret having kids they regret
starting a family
and what you're going to find every
single time with these kinds of people
is that they are very selfish and
immature and they never grew they
refused to grow
they thought that the joys of parenthood
would just come raining down
this from the sky they thought they
thought it'd be presented to them
as easy as that 27 cocktail
at the at the resort someone's just
going to hand it to them and they can
sip from it and it's a nice easy
relaxing thing
it's not you got to work for it you have
to go get it
that's the best choice in life you have
to you have to you have to
make your way through pain and suffering
to get to them and then once you're
there you know
second point though finally about this
label child free um
if you want to understand how grotesque
this label is that the media uses
casually child free well just imagine
how people would react if a father
said that his children are all straight
and describe that as gay free parenting
this is i got a gay free family it's
great this is awesome what if someone
said that
he would certainly be admonished for
describing gayness as a disease you know
that you can be
free of like cancer and yet that's
exactly how we treat children themselves
like they are disease
that uh we could be free of
when of course they're not um
and family life life with raising
children
immense happiness immense joy if you put
in the work
and so the child free movement
and the media that uh promotes it
because they're looking ultimately for
the
extinction of the human race they are
all today canceled
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated